Спершу - тренування стрільби, щоб підтримувати навички, перебуваючи
на відстані від лінії фронту.
Потім пауза. Поповнення запасів. І трохи відпочинку.
Інтернаціональний легіон був у складі української армії від самого початку
повномасштабного вторгнення Росії.
Ми просто підрозділ. Звичайний підрозділ. Просто іноземці. І ми разом з українцями.
Макс Ебергард мав дворічний досвід служби в німецькій армії.
Він приїхав в Україну вже за кілька тижнів після початку війни.
Я ніколи не думав, що в Європі знову може бути війна.
І я справді не мав важливіших справ. Хіба що нудна робота.
Я хотів допомогти людям і Зеленський теж закликав. Тому я приїхав сюди.
На початку війни Зеленський звернувся, як він сказав, до "друзів миру та демократії",
щоб вони допомогли захистити Україну.
Це вразило фінського добровольця з позивним "Гоббіт".
Мені здавалося, що Європа зробила недостатньо. І я пам’ятаю, коли у нас була війна,
у нас були добровольці, тож я подумав: принаймні я можу це зробити.
"Гоббіт" має на увазі радянсько-фінську війну 1930-х років.
Багато хто з них згадує історичний досвід своїх країн.
Добровольці з понад 60 країн взяли в руки зброю на боці України.
Це налаштованість, по суті, на готовність до рішучої боротьби за західні країни.
Це стратегічний рівень. На тактичному ж рівні, на рівні поля бою - більше нюансів.
Деякі підрозділи працюють на другій лінії, тому що вони не здатні виконувати
справді складні завдання, і їм довелося зазнати великих втрат.
Якісь підрозділи дуже ефективні, але їх не так вже й багато, лише кілька тисяч.
Тож вони не дуже відрізняються один від одного. Але я вважаю, що головний вплив
полягає в тому, щоб на стратегічному рівні зберігати настрій на протистояння агресії.
Дехто тут лише на кілька тижнів або місяців. Вони воюють пліч-о-пліч з українцями,
але іноземні бійці можуть піти і повернутися додому, якщо захочуть.
І ця різниця має суттєве значення, каже Калеб Ліст.
Коли ви в українському підрозділі, то помічаєте, що там усе чисто.
У них є люди, які готують і все організовують, і це приємно.
Тому, коли ви повертаєтеся з завдання, усе бездоганно чисте. Але з легіоном…
Оскільки він новий, там завжди є нові люди. Люди йдуть і повертаються,
тому продовжують робити ті самі помилки. Тож місця іноді брудні,
не так добре організовані. Вони не прибирають після себе.
Калеб Ліст з Австралії. Він не мав військового досвіду, коли прийшов рік тому,
але зараз вже командир взводу.
Каже, що збирався вступити до Французького іноземного легіону, коли Росія вдерлася в Україну.
Але змінив плани.
Пошук пригод, за його словами, був частиною мотивації.
Я хотів себе перевірити. Я хотів приєднатися до Французького іноземного легіону,
тому що хотів відчути екстремальну ситуацію. Тож я прийшов сюди з тією ж мотивацією
і зрештою зробив це. І зараз я займаюся цим, тому що це єдине, у чому я справді гарний.
Цей легіон не можна порівнювати з Французьким іноземним легіоном.
Так, звичайно, це підрозділ, який повністю складається з іноземців.
Але ці іноземці воюють в Україні і за Україну. Якщо вже на те пішло,
вони борються не за Фінляндію, Німеччину, Великобританію, США, Канаду чи Грузію.
Грузія, до речі, зробила істотний внесок у легіон. Вони воюють за Україну.
Це знають усі, зокрема й Росія. НАТО в цьому взагалі не бере участі.
Насправді я навіть не в курсі чуток про причетність НАТО до легіону. Це просто пропаганда.
Тут, далеко від фронту, все трохи спокійніше.
Легіон воював під українським командуванням на Бахмутському напрямку
та під час Харківської наступальної операції.
У "Гоббіта" також є і свій напівжартівливий опис їхнього найважливішого внеску у війну.
Гинути або бути пораненим кожні пару місяців, щоб Україна продовжувала бути
у заголовках газет і Захід продовжував надавати підтримку.
Я маю на увазі, що ми не збираємося цього робити, але я думаю,
що врешті-решт це виявиться найбільшим внеском, який ми можемо зробити.
Якщо припустити, що вони не зроблять такого внеску,
усі троє чоловіків кажуть, що не планують повертатися
до нормального цивільного життя.